joining me now is someone who's had
andrew tate on a very popular show leia
helper and leia thanks for joining us
you know you know tate you've spoken to
him i watch your clips clips from your
show you have some disagreements with
him on issues but you believe in his
right to speak is this a watershed
moment here is banned as people rally
around them
absolutely we are now seeing a major war
on freedom of speech and really actually
demonstrates that there's a greater
agenda going on here yes some of what
andrew says is controversial but that's
not a reason to cancel someone or
de-platform somebody also a lot of what
he said has actually been taken out of
context many of the clips re-edited in
order to portray a completely different
narrative but ultimately what we're
seeing here is a massive war on
masculinity because andrew is empowering
men to take personal responsibility he
actually teaches them how to leave the
system how to leave the matrix how to
become an entrepreneur how to leave the
night of life how to basically save
yourself because nobody is coming to
save you how to become immune from all
of this corruption that we saw and the
tyranny that we saw over the last two
years one of his most viewed videos on
youtube is actually how to fight
depression without any pharmaceutical
pills which will basically leave you
like a dead zombie all of this stuff
empowers men so of course he's being
de-platformed and canceled because
ultimately the system the powers that be
they want men in particular to be weak
fat and compliant because who is it that
fights the tyranny it's the men it's the
men that fight and it's the men that go
to war so of course they've cancelled
andrew